everybody welcome back to architects and
today I want to tackle orchard acres
which is a scenario that was also made
by Joshua and just because I've gotten
quite a few questions about this Joshua
is basically the other person who has
worked on scenarios although the actual
developers of protective also and it's
um as far as I know Maple meadows was
made by Sebastian but I'm not entirely
sure but yeah I'm usually mentioning
Joshua
because Joshua and I did just about half
of the scenario is each but also you can
find more scenarios by Joshua on his
Steam Workshop page and I don't know why
it's taken me so long to actually point
this out so I'm sorry for taking all of
this sweet time to finally explain this
but you can go to the link in the
description and check out some of the
other scenarios that Joshua has worked
on if you're interested in trying out
some other scenarios from him I do have
to say I'm not sure if they were
rejected from being scenarios in the
game or what exactly the history is
behind that I know for me there were a
few maps and ideas that never really
worked out into anything and I
ultimately didn't push through into the
game so maybe it's something like that
but I'm not entirely sure but in any
case what I'm trying to say usually with
this is that I'm quite familiar with
some of the scenarios that I've made
myself but then for some of these
scenarios that Joshua is made I might
not be quite as good at them or you know
know the ins and outs of the map quite
as well and for this one that's
certainly the case this is quite
notorious for being difficult I don't
know too much about this park but at
least I do know that it sometimes can be
a really difficult scenario if you don't
manage it well enough and we don't
really get the whole story from the
objectives here we need to just get a
Happiness rating of 70% and sell a
thousand 200 park tickets which is kind
of a different goal like it's something
that you'll eventually reach no matter
how bad your park might be but you have
to get to that happiness rating and I'm
not entirely sure how much of the
challenge is gonna come through that but
what I should say is that this map is
really special for
wait maybe I should actually show you
the description this map is pretty
special
because you have two separate plots you
have these two separate plots of
farmland on which you can build an
amusement park and maybe there's this
old guy who owns the sensor farm that
can be convinced to sell his land so I
really like the idea of this like one of
these optional goals is gonna allow us
to get the center land I suppose because
we cannot buy it normally and I suspect
that you need to get to the price
satisfaction rating of 70% and then
you'll get the land in the middle not
entirely sure but it can definitely play
a role because unless you get to that
you have to basically juggle two parks
at the same time which can be quite
difficult so you need to you know manage
two of these spaces at the same time get
sufficient food and drinks and staff and
everything in two completely separate
parks so that's kind of difficult that's
really like playing two Pike's at the
same time until you manage to open up
the space in the middle not to mention
that this is quite a large space so even
connecting the two might be quite
difficult so I also have to say I think
I'll be focusing this scenario a little
bit less on the scenery I want to keep
the the look of the the old farmland
here and basically just work my way into
these buildings so yeah it won't be
quite a scenery focused but maybe a bit
more in terms of gameplay then I'll do
some more interesting things and I still
have to figure out how good I'll be
that's trying to manage two bikes at the
same time because I've never done that
before so without further ado let's get
into it all right so my plan is to
basically build whatever I want on
either side of the fence but try to use
about half of the money for each side to
make sure that I get a decent amount of
attractions in on both sides because
something to keep in mind is that guests
will only stay in one of the two halves
of the park so each of the house of the
park is gonna need to have some gentle
rides and some more thrilling rides some
stalls and separate employees and also
whole separate scenery sets
so yeah all together this is gonna be
quite difficult now for the scenery part
of things I'm kind of inspired by the
farmhouse looks but I want to do a
little bit more than that so I'm going
for an American colonial architecture
style town which is something that I'm
not too familiar with so I definitely
can't say that I'm an expert on this
theme at all but I like it and I think
it fits into the map quite well and it
allows me to build some buildings other
than simply form buildings which adds
some more variation into the scenery so
starting off is this building which is
inspired by those colonial church
designs with the usually the the brick
buildings with a pediments in the front
in a classical Roman style and then a
really tall spire in the middle
unfortunately we don't have any brick
walls so this one is kind of the poor
man's version with wooden walls but in
the end especially for a farmers village
like this I think this might actually be
themed ethically consistent as well so
I'm pretty happy with it and even with
some very simple pieces and using the
basic shapes for the pillars because we
don't have any big pillar pieces in this
scenario I think you can actually still
do some decent looking stuff so for me
at least I was a bit shocked when I saw
just how little scenery pieces we have
to play around with in this map but I
think it's a testament to the game's
flexibilities that you can basically
just do anything with any theme if you
push it hard enough and if you try to
come up with new uses for pieces so I
put a carousel in that church building
and I'm putting a food court in one of
the existing farmhouses
and my next plan was to build a junior
coaster I'm not a huge fan of these
things but they do fit into the theme
they fit into the park went well and
it's the best coaster I have the other
coasters the mini coaster and yeah that
thing is just kind of useless especially
if I want to get some slightly more
drilling rides into the park so I'm
going for the junior coaster here and
again I'm trying to come up with
different kind of layouts that I haven't
done before so I'm playing a bit with
the path layouts that we already have in
the scenario to try and get some
interaction between the path and the
coaster but the layout itself is just
going to be a series of elixirs until
you get to the end again so quite simple
but it is hopefully going to be one of
my major moneymakers in the park because
I'm really really concerned about money
specifically I think everything else
regarding the challenges of this park
will be fine but I mean I have no
experience with a park like this but I'm
really afraid that having the guests
spread out over to different parks means
that both parks will be a little bit
less busy and you need to have extra
employees and stuff because you need to
manage the area separately and of course
I'm only going to build one roller
coaster and usually a roller coaster is
one of the biggest moneymakers but here
only about half of the visitors can
actually visit the roller coasters so
that's a bit of a concern as well so
yeah I have honestly no clue whether all
of the things that I'm building right
now are actually going to be there in
the final attempt of this scenario
because if I feel I'm gonna have to
start all over again
and I'm not even sure how I'm going to
tackle that I just I just like to
believe that I'm not going to fill this
whatever the case I finished the layouts
of the coaster and moving on to the
building for this station which is again
kind of a colonial house it's really
just the simple mention and I think
that's just one of the only buildings
that I can see matically really build in
this area I don't really want to add too
many sort of generic coaster building
stations or station buildings in general
I think there's a there's definitely a
look to station building architecture
like they're very typically prime
early a rectangle shape with a roof
supported by light supports and even if
you compare different themes
roller-coaster stations usually have
very similar shapes and I kind of wanted
to deviate from that and make it look
really much more like it could be an
actual colonial house to give it more of
the the setting to give the map more of
an overall town setting rather than a
theme park setting with a specific theme
to make it look even more as though they
are really retrofitting an existing town
into a theme park so yeah you'll see a
bunch more stations that maybe look a
bit different from what I typically do
with the station which is really just to
build a wooden framework and build a
roof over it and keep the station
entirely open on the sides but on this
one I'm really following with filling it
in with walls and windows and all of
that stuff and then for the scenery
itself
I'm keeping it quite simple and also
mostly sticking to the foliage that the
park starts off with which means a lot
of poplar trees I think those are
poplars I actually never check the name
but they look like poplars and this
standard array of bushes that I always
have and I need to use terraforming a
bit more often because I've always
forgotten to use terrain painting in
many of the scenarios that I play so I'm
painting the terrain a little bit to
have some dirt underneath the coaster as
well which I think looks pretty neat and
finally rounding this whole section up
with a spiral slide over here and at
this point I do have to admit I already
think that this side of the the park is
getting a bit unbalanced like all of the
good riots are here and I'm not saying
that because I haven't done anything in
this video yet on the other side but I
have very limited rights that I can
actually build you start off with just a
few flat rights and just two
rollercoasters and I've used most of my
decent options on the other side so I'm
gonna have to be creative in coming up
with ways to make the guests on this
side of the fence happy as well so I'm
building my second go-karts of the
series unfortunately
there also aren't many go-karts scenery
pieces available in this scenario so I'm
gonna have to be a bit creative with the
scenery in terms of that as well it's
not going to really have a racing theme
it's just going to well go through the
forest and just race through the foliage
but I think it should probably be a
decent you know flagship attraction for
this side of the park to keep people
happy I'm not entirely sure how good
go-karts are actually in park attacked I
remember in roller coaster tycoon they
were absolutely o P and people were
willing to pay insane prices for them
and they got super high excitement
ratings but in this game I'm not even
entirely sure how good these rides are
so I'm betting on this go-kart to
actually save this half of the park
until I get research to give me more
rides I'm really hoping for some good
rollercoasters because with just a
junior coaster we're definitely not
going to get there and I decided to
intermingle the go-karts and the paths a
little bit and also have a vintage car
right go through the middle of all of
that so we have a bit of a car theme
going on here which I think given that
the idea for the theme of this park
overall is some kind of orchard in an
American rural landscape I think that
fits quite well not to mention that
interaction between different tracks
rides is always nice to have I can
imagine it being pretty fun to sit on
the vintage car ride and see the
go-karts passing by and seeing people
race against each other so although at
the end of the day I'd much rather be in
the go-karts but then again go karts and
theme parks are often and separately
priced attraction and when you're in a
theme park at least for me I'd rather
skip the go-karts and go for more
typical theme park attraction things and
maeko car it's kind of a trip of its own
although maybe that suits me and to be
fair I really haven't been in a go-karts
thingamajig whatever you would call it a
go-kart stadium go-kart track I guess
that works but I haven't done it way too
long kind of
do it again but yeah I think this would
be a pretty nice track I also did put a
little bit of strategy into making the
go-carts track at least somewhat fun so
there's a lot of curves in there a
bridge going over the path and a
downward helix of course which is always
quite challenging and the tunnel
underneath the path which should also be
a nice element and overall just a lot of
s bends and tight curves so I don't know
I might not be an expert when it comes
to building racing tracks but I think
this should be a decent enough track I
really like the go-karts in architects
in terms of just how much freedom you
get to build large sweeping curves and
things like that that's always something
that kind of destroyed my imagination in
rollerCoaster Tycoon 1 because the
curves are just so insanely tight I just
kind of wish that this park would or
that this scenario would actually start
out with some of the go-karts details
like the guardrails along the sides but
that's something I can't really explain
about complaining about although come to
think of it I haven't checked if they
have the barrels or the tires in the
small scenery section I should come back
to that later because if they do have
those then I could definitely add some
of those alongside the sides of the
go-karts wreck anyway I'm keeping that
large open space in the middle of the
go-kart wreck next to the path empty
because I think that might be a good
place for a flat ride at some point
later in the scenario I'm basically
praying that I actually get a flat right
that fits in there because some of the
flat rides in this game are absolutely
huge so I might not even get a right
that fits in there but if I do get
something like I don't know a swinging
ship or anything really one of the 4x4
thrill rides or gentle rides that would
be a really nice addition in the middle
of that area and I'm also adding a small
area with a ferris wheel I think for the
other side of the park we have the
church as the major weenie and you kind
of have a small Bulevar leading up to
the church which is quite nice and on
this side I also wanted to have a weenie
but I also needed another flat ride so I
think the ferris wheel should do both
functions all right and yeah that is the
overall design for this area quite
simple
and it's similar to the other area but
this one feels a bit more urban and a
bit more gardened whereas the other one
to me at least feels a bit more Foresti
and they definitely do have different
theme but altogether I also think they
work quite well with the buildings that
are already in the game this station
building for the vintage cars kind of
has an English looking chimney but I
think altogether it could still fit into
American colonial architecture and the
same inspiration kind of goes for this
station of the go cards as well which is
perched on top of a little hill and kind
of has a view over the entire plaza here
so altogether I think it's a decent set
up of buildings and finally I'm adding a
small barn over here which I'm placing
the foodcourt inside and using some of
that White's timber work that you'll
sometimes see on barns just for some
detail and I think that should be a good
sort of counter parts for the barn food
courts on the other half of the park in
any case as you can see I'm actually
quickly running out of money so at this
point I had to stop theming because I
had no money anymore and even taken a
loan so that's kind of a problem so yeah
I've played the game on paused mode so
far I think it's a good idea to actually
play it for a bit and see if I can
somehow run a profit on this park
alright so I'm gonna do something that I
haven't done on any of my playthrough so
far and I'm gonna do a bit of
management's live because this is
currently crucial and if this goes
horribly wrong I at least want to have
some proof of what happened and how it
happened if not for you guys then maybe
even for myself so I can go back and see
what went wrong so we have to open
everything and I think yeah nothing's
really open yet
I have no idea how much money you can
ask people for the go-karts I'm gonna
start with six dollars and I'm just
gonna jack up the price until they don't
want to pay for it anymore
I'm really hoping that people really
want to pay up for it because otherwise
I think I'm royally screwed this thing
has zero ratings it's waiting for new
test results which fair enough
I'm gonna need to play the game
eventually for that and this one has an
excitement of twenty eight that's quite
a lot I've noticed in general that
scenery while being extremely expensive
really does help ratings quite a bit so
I'm really happy that at least scenery
plays a role in gameplay if you choose
to go for it very much like it did in
rollercoaster tycoon
at least on a number of the scenarios
that said of course the game can't
really figure out what looks nice
because that's very subjective and
there's really no objective measure for
it so you could also you can always just
spam bushes and make everything look
really ugly with a lot of scenery pieces
and you'll get high ratings for it but
altogether I'm happy that at least you
know the effort that I put into making
parks look nice gets rewarded in terms
of gameplay on some level now I need
some janitors so I'm just gonna put one
janitor and one mechanic and each side
of the park I'm gonna need some haulers
to get this stuff to the shops we've got
the depot here and then we've got
another Depot here and yeah that should
be more or less fine and then of course
I'm also going to need a janitor and a
mechanic in here that's all that I'm
gonna start off with I really don't want
to go too far yet I first want to see
how much money I can actually earn then
there's also the question of research as
I already pointed out I have a very
limited amount of rides on this scenario
these are some gentle rides we've used
all of these the thrill rides we've used
all of these the coaster well I haven't
done anything with the mini coaster but
you can forget about it and then there
are some water rights which are really
not all that good and I don't have a big
pond or lake to use anyway so yeah I
guess I could use the calm river ride
for something but that's
like a car ride and I don't want to turn
this park into a trip still where 90% of
the rides are just tract rides
no offense the trips drill they're
absolutely beautiful but that's not
something I want to go for here I think
that's a decent enough starts I'm just
really curious to see if I can even earn
any money on this park I'd be happy to
break even even at this point as soon as
I noticed that I'm breaking even or that
I'm losing money though I think I'm just
gonna pause the game again although no I
should probably keep it running for a
while to get some research to get first
of all a jumper that'll be quite useful
has a decent intensity rating but at
some point I should also get a new shop
because it's a little bit inconvenience
that I haven't really mentioned so far
is even the shops that we get are very
limited and we've got the necessities
thank God we have toilets and an info
kiosk actually I didn't want to ruin my
experiment experience by looking up a
playthrough of this scenario just as I
haven't done that with any of the
scenarios that I've played so far these
are all blind playthroughs but that said
I did read a few guides and they pointed
out that info kiosks are a no-go on the
scenario because people will get a map
and will want to go to the other side of
the park then they can't and I'm not
entirely sure if this is true or not
based on that risk I don't want to risk
putting down an info kiosk
I'll just get umbrella stores when the
time comes and when it starts raining
speaking of which I'm definitely gonna
play some of those as well but I'm first
gonna wait I have no idea what the
climate is like exactly in this scenario
it's currently minus 3 Celsius so it's
extremely cold but I'm not sure how much
precipitation we're gonna get in this
one anyway
I think people are actually getting on
this thing that's pretty good
what's that person's name just now
forget about it I thought that person
had a really strange name but I didn't
quite catch it
okay so people are willing to put down
is $7.00 for this I mean they're willing
to put that six but I'm gonna hike that
up to seven hopefully people are still
willing to go on this that should be a
decent income at least but that said
overall it looks like I'm not going to
make any profit on this let's speed up
the simulation in tiny bits
I'm keeping costs down as much as I can
having not too much staff and everything
oh I haven't opened all of the rice yet
I should definitely do that this should
be super point one at least based on the
excitement rating could even possibly be
a little bit more I could always try and
micromanage some of the prices if I end
up getting in money trouble but yeah
this should at least bring in some extra
guests again I think people are enjoying
this coaster I should probably make this
one a little bit more expensive see if
they want to pay eight bucks for this
probably not but if they do then that's
great well that's doing all right
actually god I need to change the color
scheme that I haven't changed the colors
of the cars yet so I'm definitely gonna
want to change that I already got a
Happiness rating of at least 70% so
never mind that's not going to be the
challenge of this park the challenge is
trying to stay afloat and not let the
fight go bankrupt I suppose and really
like these colors I'd like to go for
something of a wooden kind of look oh
this yellow yeah there is the imminent
bankruptcy right so by the end of May I
need to make profits god
okay sure all right we got the jumper
I'm gonna decrease the money that I'm
putting into research by quite a bit
research shops or okay I'm just gonna
research shops I really don't want
people to start complaining because they
have nothing to drink which is the
problem that I have at the moments God
looks like people are still queuing up
for this even though it's seven bucks
all right let's make it eight then let's
keep going until they stop going on this
oh this is losing right and this is
losing money oh I can I can probably
hack this up to four dollars
first wheel people are still getting on
this in fact the queue time is too long
so let's make that tiny bit expensive I
don't think they'll pay more than $3
though but I'm gonna try it with 350
first all right now as for this coaster
people are still paying eight bucks for
it but I think there are less people in
it maybe I'm wrong but kind of seems
that way it's making a profit anyway so
that's good
and I could probably wait the excitement
rating on this just go up by a lot
whatever I could probably raise this to
$3 see people willing to pay that and
the carousels closed God why do I always
forget to open rides that's really dumb
and I'm gonna try and make this two
dollars hopefully people are willing to
pay that maybe this is a little bit too
expensive but we'll see
whatever the case and that's minus 62 in
a month so that's almost the profits at
least I might be able to avoid
bankruptcy
I'm gonna save right here because this
month is gonna be everything I forgot to
open this thing of course classic silver
at move right there that's the strategy
really to forget to open things and then
make the video really exciting and make
you wonder whether or not
actually gonna make it to reveal that I
had an ace up my sleeve all the time no
I just always forget to open rides but I
think with the twister here we should be
able to draw in more guests and that
should hopefully fill up the rides a bit
better
Oh God a group of vandals is just about
the last thing that I needed right now
all right so I'm gonna switch the
decoration and see where those vandals
are ads so if I catch one of them in the
act I can at least ban them and that'll
save me a lot of trouble later on yeah
because I don't have money to replace
anything oh oh that just happened okay
who is this I just saw something being
broken but I don't see any vandals as
far as I'm aware usually if you see a
vandal they are wearing a bandana so I
think oh oh there he is
get out of here so he's getting banned
but there are probably some more yep is
another one alright you are leaving the
park sir you too okay god that's a lot
of vandals and you would have even gone
on two go-karts that's a shame I think
that's it but judging but no no no no
nope get out of here judging by the look
of the park
they already did a lot of damage oh my
god
all right then I'll get one of my
mechanics I'm gonna have to check where
my mechanics are so this mechanic is
here so this is the mechanic that I'm
gonna have to pick up and fix the
vandalism with oh but we also have some
vandals running over here so I'm gonna
have to check that as well
I'll let the game play in a second but
for now I like to pause the game while
I'm searching for the Vandals because
they should still be pretty close to the
stuff that they destroyed at least
they're very recognizable I'll give them
that it's a bit ironic that really
they're using these bandanas to hide
their identity
but the fact that they're wearing them
is giving me the clues that they are the
the vandalizes I think that's it
there might be another one but yeah I
think that's most of them oh there we go
here's another one
Carl that's a lot of handles not gonna
lie these guys are kind of overpowered
they they were really able to
single-handedly destroy the whole look
of your park and bring your rating down
but I'm making a profit at least that's
really good so from this point onward I
can at least take a bit of a breather
it's gonna take a while to actually get
back into the positives again but I
think for now if I just let the game run
for a bit and try to manage anything
that goes wrong I can make a profit get
back into enough money to build some
more rides and then things should start
rolling from there again so yeah I
avoided bankruptcy so I'm really happy
with that now let's see if I can build
some other stuff soon all right so I'm
starting off with a wild mouse coaster
which is not my favorite coaster type
but it's what the research gods decided
to bless upon me I did have the wooden
coaster as well but I want to fit that
in somewhere else and also I don't like
the powered coasters so that was out of
the question anyway I mean this is a
decent coaster type don't get me wrong I
think from a gameplay perspective it's
actually really good you can built these
things very cheaply and people will
really appreciate it and pay a lot of
money for these things and as long as
you space out your block brakes well
enough you can get people to pay a lot
of money for these as well and I know
Marcel Faust doesn't really like these
in roller coaster tycoon because all of
the block brake shenanigans but this is
Park attacked and we have to really be
realistic and if we need a high-capacity
ride we really have to get those block
brakes in order so yeah altogether it's
a nice ride type it's just always the
same you just have some hairpin turns
and some drops and that is basically it
so with this layout I'm trying to
deviate from the standard
well mouse layout as much as I can but
it's really difficult these things are
typically placed on a rectangular layout
with always the hairpin turns and it
drops in the same locations so all that
I'm really doing here is building the
standard layouts but just kind of
shuffling with the order of things and
with the placements of things still not
the greatest thing but at least it's a
bit more interesting than a regular wild
mouse and you can adapt it somewhat to
the terrain so I have more space here
than a standard Mouse layout would take
so I'm deciding to use at least as much
of that space as I realistically can
while keeping this also a believable
Wild Mouse layouts I don't think that
from a gameplay perspective it will be
too important because I'm already
earning some decent money as well but
part of the reason why I built the wall
mouse first is also just because it's
such a cheap coaster I really didn't
have the money to afford anything big
yet and this thing should also earn me
some extra cash for when I do decide to
build the wooden coaster also kind of
funny I decided to play around with a
color scheme for this coaster quite a
bit and really what I usually just do is
drag those color sliders randomly until
I find something that looks alright well
not and not completely randomly at least
going off of color schemes that I know
from heart but I ended up going with the
almost default color scheme of yellow
and blue these are slightly different
shades from what you start off with but
it's actually very similar to the
default color scheme of this ride which
is something then I normally don't
really like doing but for some reason I
kind of feel like it fits into the vibe
of this scenario for some reason not
sure why it just feels right compared to
all of the other safer options that I
was looking into and I think also this
ride is should probably finish off this
area of the park quite neatly because
I'm already getting somewhat close to
the core of this scenario I have to say
once I got past the stage where I kept
going Bank
but this scenario became a whole lot
easier and now it's almost too easy I
don't want to say that too quickly or
I'll definitely jinx it but yeah judging
by how quickly I'm storming towards the
final goal for this scenario I do want
to start wrapping up things I'm not
going to use the entire space of this
park
so this Walt Mouse is where I'm kind of
proclaiming the park border this is the
one final large structure that kind of
closes off the rest of the park that I
won't be using and the orchards which
I'll just leave alone because even
though this is a park themed to orchards
I'm really just building around those
rather than building on the same spot
which I guess kind of makes sense I'm
pretty sure that this scenario is
inspired by an existing old scenario in
rollercoaster tycoon of which I'm not
entirely sure what the name is anymore
or which expansion packet came with it
definitely came with an expansion pack
but roller coaster tycoon had a scenario
as well where you were building a theme
park in an orchard and it always kind of
irked me that while you were doing that
you were basically destroying the
orchard itself so I don't know that was
it was kind of strange and I think there
are a lot of scenarios with ethical
issues like that and at least this park
doesn't really have that it kind of
seems like some of these farmhouses were
abandoned no they're not used anymore
they're completely empty but you still
have an active orchard nearby and it
just provides a nice sort of setting for
a theme park and I think it's to an
extent even a realistic one I definitely
seen the theme parks with at least you
know farm themes like this they're
usually not very big but it's always a
nice setting for a charming theme park
anyway I guess that's a little bit of an
off topic ramble about the whole idea of
agricultural theme parks it's just it's
an interesting thing for sure maybe it
could even be used for educational
reasons you know sometimes theme parks
can definitely take on more of a social
role either keeping certain traditions
or cultures in in vogue and making it
through commercializing it at least
still somewhat relevance or educating
people about animals or nature or
certain kind of culture you know I think
there's a there are uses for theme parks
other than just entertainment especially
zoos I think as a sort of subset of
amusement park can fill that kind of
role anyway I said I was going off-topic
wasn't I so I'm just filling off filling
in the rest of that area or I was just
filling in the rest of that area with
another flat ride and that's basically
that's for that side of the park so now
I'm going back to manage to this side of
the park finish some of the scenery that
I left behind but after all of that it
is finally time to do something which
I've been wanting to do the whole time
with this point because I think
somatically it fits and it also just
really fits the map with the world with
the road running past the park and that
is to build a wooden coaster here very
often especially with some of these
older parks with their out-and-back
wooden coasters you'll see that wooden
coasters are kind of a billboard for the
park and you see that nowadays with a
lot of different coasters as well if you
go to Six Flags parking lots or Cedar
Point for parking lots you'll see
another with coasters next to the
parking lots as well or even on the
parking lot if you're Six Flags Magic
Mountain but it used to be very much a
typical thing to do with wooden coaster
so you always have these long out and
back wooden coasters next to the parking
lot or the public road to kind of
advertise for hey there's a there's a
theme park here that might be worth
visiting and that's the one thing that
I'm really doing with this we're I'm
trying to put this on this play as much
as I can trying to even alternate some
of those airtime Hills you know so that
it all weaves nicely in and out of each
other if you're looking from the side of
the road
and yeah that's basically the point of
this wooden coaster and it kind of
connects the two parks as well because I
I couldn't really realistically fill in
the space between the parks with real
you know park sections with a different
theme land with all kinds of different
rides but I think that the easiest way
to kind of connect these two parts of
the park is to build a coaster between
it which I know visually connects both
sides of the theme park well at the same
time leaving the entire orchard intact
and not really messing with that in any
big way so yeah I don't know I I don't
wanna Pat myself on the back too much
but I think this wooden coaster was a
pretty good idea it's not the most
exciting though and these are always
kind of boring layouts to build as well
because really all you just do is up and
down turn around and go up and down
again and yelling you're pretty much
done but I think it fits the theme too
well and it fits the general layouts of
the park really well I will be making a
path over here as well so that's why I
am also fencing off some of the existing
paths there to prevent people from
walking into the orchard which was
actually accidentally happening and if
they earlier I was knowing just to make
sure that people can actually walk
between the two sides of the park
so you're not getting ripped off anymore
getting in park tickets because once
again returning to ethics I think it is
quite an ethical to have two parks with
the same ticket you know if you're not
well educated about which attractions
are in which side of the park then you
might have gone into the wrong side a
completely screwed and if you want to do
all attractions you would have to buy
two tickets I think there is just
there's all kinds of problematic issues
related to the whole two parks won
tickets thing so yeah we should probably
solve that and I think having a path in
between the two halves it's probably the
best way to do that and finally for the
station I really couldn't care much
about how this station looks a wooden
coaster stations in general tend to be
quite simple and religious a platform
with a roof
supported by a wooden supports wooden
frameworks so I'm really not deviating
from that formula too much I just wanted
to play it safe at this point maybe mess
with a few roof shapes but in the end I
couldn't really find much that I thought
looks good anyway so yeah keeping this
all quite simple really just the bare
minimum that works and fits into the
rest of the theme of the park but yeah
that is basically all I have to do and
say for this part of the episode now I
was kind of running into a bit of a
problem because I was almost reaching
the objectives of the scenario but I was
nowhere near finished with the park so I
hope you'll excuse me if we just take
another quick moments to in real time
see the objectives be met and see
everybody celebrates and then afterwards
I'll try to finish up some of the stuff
that I left hanging in the rest of the
park all right there we go
I caught it oh [ __ ] I need to hold it
for three weeks well time for a small
time-lapse then I'm gonna try and do as
much as I can with the amount of money
and time that I have left which is
mostly foliage related stuff I'm
finishing some of the paths that didn't
really lead anywhere I'm just closing
those off adding a bunch of foliage and
detailing around the wooden coaster and
also the part going through the orchard
which I'm actually finishing for once
which I hadn't done yet and adding a few
path elements and fences along the route
as well it's all quite simple and really
not that detailed and I'm not even
adding any more rides but it's just
about all that I could do with the money
and time that I've left and I think it's
a decent way to finish this scenario
before reaching the objective so let's
see how it turned out alright then
now we should be good to go alright and
that's it that's a wrap overall I'm
actually really glad that I finally
finished the scenario I know it's not
something that you guys have experienced
in this video but I've had to restart
this save so many times
so I'm just really glad to get this over
with this was without a doubt the most
difficult scenario so far at least for
me personally and it's the one where I
kind of had to throw away some of my
ideas about theming and scenery in order
to actually finish the scenario that
said I am quite happy with the final
results it might not be as heavily
themed and as densely packed as some of
the parks so far but I do think it fits
into the orchard theme decently and I
didn't have to restart anything I would
have been so depressed if I had to throw
away all of my progress just because I
couldn't make the park work somehow I
managed to make it work and I'm really
happy about that just want to give you
guys a quick overview of everything that
I built in the entire video so we've got
the Jr coaster here which is a pretty
simple coaster with very simple stats
honestly not even that much of a
moneymaker it's only started to make
decent money in oops likes byte in the
last couple of months when there's been
more guests in the park but until that I
really had to put a lot of advertisement
on this ride to get people to ride it
and it still doesn't make that much
money that said I think as as as far as
realism goes it's good that we've got it
here in the park it really fits into the
scenery
then the wooden coaster of course I do
want to do it quick 4v of this one as
well let's get the other train there we
go I gave this thing six seater trains
actually I need to increase the minimum
waiting time and that one don't want it
to standstill on the lift so but yeah I
gave it six seater trains just because
it's very much a classic out and back
wooden coaster and classic wooden
coasters typically have these larger
cars so I think that fits it's a little
bit slow here on the turnaround but
that's also very much a traditional
woody kind of thing and it catches some
decent airtime on some of these hills
classic double up as well maybe could
have done that as a double down as well
but I like it the way it fits at the
moment
and finally some slightly more twisty
bits at the end but even though these
bits are a bit more twisty they're still
quite simple really
a mosquito just flew in front of my face
I think I can hopefully find that thing
again because I am going to bed soon and
I don't want to deal with that anyway
that's the wooden coaster and the last
thing to maybe go over for a bit is
probably the what Mouse coaster which
should be doing its block sections all
right I had an earlier time when the
block sections weren't set up correctly
so they would all have to stop here and
there but now it should be one smooth
ride until maybe something breaks down
or something like that but yeah that's
pretty much as I talked about earlier
it's just such a simple coaster with a
simple layout every time that there's
really not too much that you can you
know add in terms of variation it's just
hairpin turns and ups and downs and
that's that's basically it but as far as
that layouts premise goes I think this
is a decent way to at least some
variation by having an ending slightly
different orders and how even make it a
bit taller I really like it when oh god
I don't like that it still stops in the
last break room hmm
could have maybe fix that but yeah I
really like it when wild mouse coasters
have a large drop and some point in
their layouts I know that the one in
Europa Park which I wrote recently has
this really cool first drop after the
lift hill a lift hill which is also
really awesome part of the write that I
don't a spoil because if you're ever
going to europa park and you don't know
what the lift Hill of that what Mouse
coaster is like it's a really cool
experience and it's especially cool if
you don't see it coming anyway that's
our wild mouse here and then the last
area that's kind of interesting is the
one with the go-karts which I'm actually
decently happy with as well so yeah
altogether I'm glad that I managed to
finish the scenario at all and with a
decent-looking park that's after all of
the bankruptcy troubles that I went
through with the new coasters and all
the new rides
actually doing really well right now but
God was this one really difficult this
one totally beat me up as far as I've
heard from a lot of people many people
seem to have said that this was the
scenario that they struggled with the
most so from here on out maybe it
shouldn't be getting easier per se but
at least I shouldn't have to be as
afraid of going bankrupt but still
something that I should stay on the
lookout for because I really don't know
what I'll do if I put a lot of effort
into a park and I eventually have it go
bankrupt and don't find a way to somehow
manage to finish it oh yeah and one
thing I forgot I got the trophy and the
trophy is this farm house building here
the next scenario that we get is I'm not
entirely sure actually but let's see
Hickory Hill I didn't think that was
already coming up here but I know what
that is and I'm looking forward to it
but I think the next episode will
probably be coaster Canyon anyway we'll
see you when the time comes
bye guys